few things are as important to American
prosperity it's how our schools fare
when it comes to teaching science
technology and math our scores on this
counter middling at best meanwhile a
major international analysis recently
reported on STEM practices across dozens
of nations including many of our leading
competitors how did the u.s. stack up
American students do more math homework
than their peers abroad in 2015
seventy-five percent of US eighth
graders at home work at least twice a
week that was 20 points higher than the
OECD average u.s. 4th graders observed
science experiments about as frequently
as their peers in the typical OECD
nation and American students use
computers in math class far more than to
their peers overseas in 2015 4 & 5 u.s.
4th graders frequently used computers
more homework plenty of experiments more
computers but middle and scores more of
the same probably isn't the answer we
just may need a new playbook how do you
think u.s. STEM education stacks up
internationally let us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI